Krieg in Israel Gaza in der Ukraine
dazuen Naturkatastrophen Klimakrise all
das lassen wir Tag für Tag in der medie
viel ist das viel und sie schaltet ab es
zieht sie aber einige les gar keine News
mehr über
[Musik]
daseden ja heute Demokratie istforor
wenn wir kein News mit konsumiert das
mein einige Philosoph das stimmt W
bespreche aber zu dir Bar zu den
Schrecken nachrte katastropheldige was
mchen i mit dir also es zieht mich
natürlich auch aber W unmch wenn es
nicht so wä sind irgendwie schwierige Z
wobi ist auch interessant dass man auch
immer wieder feststellt Z sind schon
viel schlimmer g das vergisst man
schnell also schon nur vor 100 Jahr
überleid Zweite Weltkrieg also ist
insgesamt vielleicht vi weltw geh besser
aber die FL die viele
Bilder zu dem führt was man do scrolling
nennt oder V ein Katastrophe zu andere
immer SCR so
selbstch ich wo News konsumiert und das
du beschribst natürlich
mobil
Streich ich Problem mit Mails unterwegs
das ist für miching wenn
ich vi
so mir so ich nicht auf die Art und
konsumieren ich Z abonniert oder Einzel
App mich interessiert sehr gezielt g
entsprechmen mega vi einfach so und das
oder ist wie die Welt ist ganz schlecht
und die Ursache warum machen wir das ein
mit algori du das du h Bild lang
Text weg und soziale medie irgendwie das
endlose SCR immer meh Algorithmus SPI
immer me von dem in was D packt die
Angst super funktioniert oder der ursach
warum so such oder die negative
schlagziele genau sogenannte negativity
bi D man ja wei der vch das negative
Nachrichten meh fest das Positive
Nachrichte das verstärkt das natürlich
dlick wenn irgendwo katastrophig ist als
irgend positiv das sch mir sch großes
Problem und gichzetig danke ja Stück
find muss man sich mit der Welt
auseinandersetz also der totale Rückzug
das ist die sogenannte News avoidance
also Menschen wo sich ganz bewusst sag
ich möch mit dem du ich vertrag ich
Verst vom Empathie Burnout Begriff Prät
worden ist d wirklich einfach n m W se
empathisch sie aber irgendw l einfach
viel interessant phomen in dem Zang das
mean world Syndrome das ist schon 70
jreforcht von usamerikan ge heißt der
und das heißt eigentlich wenn du viel
konfrontiert bist mit negativ schlagziel
glaubst du irgendein ist Welt ist ein
sehr bedrohlichen Ort wo der nicht
wohlgesonen ist und wo gefährlich ist
viel mehr also völlig verzerrt oder git
verzerrt Bild führt zu angststörige zu
Depressionen zu Wurt sogar Z
suchtverhalt also ist sehr gut derforch
fin recht krass und ich glaub überol von
der Medi sicher n Red demammenhang oder
es geht natürlich die großen entwickl wo
du zeigt wo zum Teil sehr positiv sind
aber die Einzel Ereignis wo Bild so die
sind F negativ und das ist so dass ich
gemein und bös aber ich kenne das B wenn
so einen terrorchlag viel drüber lest
ich muss gar nicht Bilder mir lang
drüber l dass ich merke dass ich
plötzlich im trumum mich
und das irgend bedrohlich finde das WSS
dass Mensche
WoT Menschen wo friedliche Bürger sind
plötzlich und machen das H bedroh
ja wir wsen noch nicht was das alles mit
macht oder bpren got soen oder und die
Regelmäßigkeit und gich das
Suchtverhalten Trigger die algorithme
natürlich oder und vielleicht so wie die
fear of missing out oder verpassen muss
do auf laufen also ich das alles weniger
ich ich Amfang von Krise z Corona
Ukraine Israel jetzt ich die die
verunsicherig wo ich viel W wüs und ich
unglaublich viel lese und konsumierere
nachher hab ich aber irgendwie wie so
ein natürlicher Selbstschutz wo
irgendwie das das wegt und ich merke es
tut mir nicht gut und ich find das muss
man auch spüren sich selber beobachten
und dann darf man al wen Z got finde ich
darf man auch sich distanzieren ja die
negativ schlagziele die Mö mit aber der
AW glaub nicht dass man gar nicht
konsumier es ist ja so dass immer meh l
zeiget Studie sich bewusst distanziert
also die News avoidance das vermiedet
das sind ein Drittel von der Bevölkerung
macht das regelmäßig oder misch ich
würde mich dazuzähen übrigens dass es ab
und zur bewusst welecke und andere
Phänomen wo jetzt drüber red ist
natürlich das dass es lü geht wo gar
kein News konsumiert W es irgendwie aus
ganz unterschiedliche gründ die
sogenannte News deprivierte viele jung
ja
irgendwie n 5 7 Minuten am Tag g l und
viele ke Zugang sprochbarriere oder
schtige Sachen GLB das ist das Problem
für Demokratie das Reden ich wer gerade
mit dir reden aber noch mal zurück mich
wirklich interessiert ich meine was ist
newsance wenn man natürlich die drunter
zäht und regelmäßige tagestig oder
irende App konsumiert aber wo trotzdem
Bücher l z.B dann finde ich komische
Begriff oder in Israel Gaza vielleicht
se die viele News die sind schon
irgendwie wichtig aber ich w der
Konflikt versten und das Buch zum Thema
lesen oder Dokumentarfilm zum Thema und
rumst verstst du viel mehr von de
Konflikt V deine ganz spannf wenn du wir
und ist Rut Brechmann
Historiker wo dasiert und seit die viele
viele News die machen das halbes
wahnsinniguck ganz ganz schlimm und H
trotzdem nicht wirklich Verst was
und letztlich Verständnis das wo wichtig
ist für Demokratie dass man nacher
informiert überhaupt abstimmen z. klar
damit du nicht nur Informationen aufs
sondernhang Verst grü Verst dichelber
positionieren und das ist der
meinsbildig Prozess ja W natürlich auf
dem Biert ich finde und was interessant
Fin klimaphysiker und er feststellt dass
die klimaangst wo viel junge Hand dass
die verbreitet den wo nicht extrem damit
auseinandetz das erinnert mich F so B
Angst vor der Spinne ich weiß natürlich
wenn ich mich meh mit der Spinnen
auseinandetze was ich natürlich nicht
möchte will ich Angst vor Spin aber wenn
ich mich me dam mituseinandersetze Gott
Angst inner zurück und ich glaube das
stimmt sogar bezüglich de Konflikt vi
ich nicht immer aber die News hab ja so
bis bedroh genau W es nicht Kön das BBT
fremd oder und fremde Macht Angst
Terrorattacken und denkt das passiert
plötzlich wie ein Vulkan BR böse Mens
und
erupicht ist anders Bild wiefül Teil von
Schw Konflikt
jetzt die Demokratie Rede und der
Journalismus sozusag als als surstoff
der Demokratie oder wo man irgend BR die
KCH abstimmen und W Partei und und so
weer es geht V berühmter Philosoph gibt
die formulier dass er se okay med sind
wir die vier die Gewalt oder die vier sü
oder
Exekutive Legislative Judikative geh die
publikative oder so eine wichtige Stütz
ist demokratiees recht W nch wenn du
dich nicht frei frei Meinungsbild oder
das ist das Grundrecht verfass oder und
das Erkennen ich GLB das kann man nicht
genug aufag oder wenn nach Russland Mens
rund um bescht werd
mit
ha
propagandaomen
zide dass der Prinip der Fürst der muss
sogar Lüge nur recht der muss Volk
belügen gut und das gehört zu der Macht
dazu aber natürlich riesen Thema die
ganze Fake News Propaganda wie mit dem
um und dann
wi rechtf auf die vier Gewalt wo medie
Politik kontrolliert überwacht iordnet
und dass es das Privileg ist die freie
medie ich g das mE Schwiz wenig bewusst
bundesr geht immer noch W der konsumiert
keine oder
wasürchre also wenn das Signalfunktion
ist das natürlich problematisch od nicht
nur gesagt ich konsumiere kein gesagt
das bringt mir gar nicht und noch den
relativiert undk wahsinig
wer natürich die doss und und so zu Z
bra Entscheid treffen Teams und so ich
glaube ist ein ander Fall ja aber das
zeigen ist schon mal problematisch we
ich total interessant finde Du vorher
Artikel verfass zitiert und spannend ist
ja dass wir eigentlich
rechtf freie Meinungsbildung Artikel 16
ab genau recht
schön und jetzt diskutieren wir Z
eigentlich über Pflicht also nicht nur
über frag hab das rechtf das hab das ist
Schwiz verbrie geschützt werden kan
drüber diskutiere wie frei ist PR
wirklich noch aber es geht Frage nach
der Pflicht glaubst du es geht Pflicht
im moralischen Sinn sich sich gut zu
informieren ich finde es gibt Pflicht
quasi resultierend aus der Dankbarkeit
dass man in der Demokratie le und
Demokratie braucht frei medie insofern
geht Pflicht irgendwie informiert Z das
finde ich ich persönlich finde hte
Pflicht irgende Form von Media zu
abonnieren will es ist völlig klar
gratis Journalismus funktioniert nicht
also ich zahle Z Abos gern auch mit der
überzig dass man Journalismus muss
unterstützen ich bin unsicher ich weiß
nicht was ist wo irgendwie der ganzag
krüppelt und ke Lust auf das Züg und und
einfach s la le ich finde das darf man
machen mir muss nicht abstimmen darf
sich d einfach nicht beklagen drüber
wenn es nicht so läuft wie W aber fin
Grund Plicht würde ich jetzt glaub nicht
unterschrieben ja ohne Media gab's keine
freie Meinungsbild und damit auch ke
funktionieren die demokratieo das bestr
ist wahrscheinlich der rolfelli berümte
Schwizer Autor wo sich bekannt dass ke
News l al Kes Radi los ke fernseht
sondern mit und er l Bücher
dasstategie frit und das ich
wo man vi wenig
geuseinanderset Bücheren sich ich find
schon je nachdem was für Bücher l D das
hilf zum hintergrü Verst gerade
toal ich kritisch aber du
h und gefund D
positionf ja ich finde es im was man
selberournalism schaff kann man
irgendwie leiste ich find sch kann man
sich wschinlich leisten wenn man also mE
sehr neugierige gut informierte Bild
Bild Autor wo wahrscheinlich viel mehr
weiß als die allermeisten oder und dem
finde ich jetzt nicht so problematisch
aber glaub am schüber reden was es für
Schutzstrategie be geht weiß wie man mit
dem ich die News sind 30% von der
Bevölkerung Mö oder sie ab nicht gut
geht Strategie also mir z.B helfft ist
und da bin ich wahrscheinlich wirklich
sehr alte Schule ich habe immer noch
gern Papier zittigge das heißt ich ne
zittig gendwn briefasten und les die
ztig natürlich nicht von hin bis vorne
oder von vorne bis hinen aber irgendwann
ist die ztig fertig und dann tun sie auf
salpapier und das hilft irgendwie ich
habe so die Z die Z les und Z fertig und
dann le auf Z und der wie dum Scroller
Gefühl der ganz kommt neu kom ne ne
S
und du halb Stund drafen oder was ich
interessant finde sind Newsletter das
gibt's ja auch immer mehr mediüer das S
Newsletter schicket wo du ser pass genau
Stellen zu was du möchtest informiert
Sie und das Mussum sag noch g also
gerade Meder den so Samml ein der Woche
die wichtigste keine Nachrichten aus der
Literatur oder philosophische Newsletter
wo ein so bündelt was anderen Medi
wierum ist das Fin ein interessantes
Phänomen das denn kan den andere Medium
den zah Einzel Artikel find aber wieder
gut D den das ist Wert ich zah jetzt
Euro und ich
WK sehr bewusst Umgang mit Media würde
ich sagen
viier mit passiert du bist in dem in dem
soendwi die pushm du l du scroll du
fühst dich nicht gut machst lst dich ab
mit irg also ist wirklich so
suchtmechanismus für ganz viele oder und
ist meine vielleicht selbstbeobachtig
hilft natürlich oder warum ma ich jetzt
die App oder und noch wenn sie zu mach h
mir Kolf was hab ich GEW ich glaub die
Form von distanzier V kurzem wet und sag
was was ist das G was gemacht das ist
mega wichtig oder ja und das ist ein
bildigsftrag oder die ganze
Medienkompetenz mehr und mehr wieder m
leren mit der verschieb der
medilandschaft mit der ganze
digitalisier riesen Thema oder ich bin
aufgeachsen mit Elter wo nur Z noch ke
soziale medie kein onlinemi und dem
Bernhard per
mediwissenschaftler bra so wie eine
redaktionelle Gesellschaft nenn das ist
im Buch und appelliert ein me Schulen
bildig das ist immer natür entlösig dass
man se sch m aber ist auch schwierig man
kann nicht immer alles bildig abschie
Schu so viel Leist also ich fin
gesamtgesellschaftlich
natür wirke muss man Kind Vorbild und
versuch zeigen wie konsumiert mit auf
Handy l was l sie sie wo untersched ist
zwischen influencer und med publiziert
sind alle auf tiktok und
Instagram Problem weniger bei der junge
Generation der älter Generation ehrlich
mit dem Internet ich im
Internet h ab zu verwandreis und dann
sage ich wo h das Russ today und das zü
und das zü es ist einfach im Internet
und das ist das Fake News Problem oder
al die Medi Kompetenz die gar nicht
recht das sind die jung schon viel
besser drin aber ich fin gerade der
schwizo so eine direkte Demokratie h ist
das ein wichtigen Auftrag das he klar
ist wir mü politische bildig und
medikompetenz wirklich irgendwie
vorrieben in Schweden z. wird alle
abiturabgänger und abgängerin
Buch verteilt von der Philosophin das
heißt alternativ Fakta auf Deutsch hören
sagen komische übersetzig wo es um die
Fake News Geschichte geht von der
Philosophin as wfor und das ist wirklich
gut Buch ich das mit großer begeister wo
wo ein aufzeigt wir eigentlich
Alternative fakte wie der Begriff
überhaupt entstanden ist was damit
gemeint ist was überhaupt faktum ist was
Begriff der wor ist und warum der so
prekär worden ist
mega PR also
wenn Ukraine und Israel g
alles geschickt werdet und so das ist
Wahnsinn das ist wirklich also ist
riesusforder für Journalismus das kan
und die und gwichtchaffen oder D
trotzdem das L und nicht die andere
sacheo so neu und so attraktiv sind
großartige Tips jetzt find schon einfach
TS Welt ist globalisier
ein me groß W unfassbar groß sind
konfrontiert mit News V der ganze Welt
das großartig du Radi sprach WN die
sprach aber gich ja das viele Elend das
got so ist es ja auf laufen das ist
wichtig Demokratie aber es geht Granze
und wen psychische Gesundheit
soaran ja was die vermeldig mit
schri sie Kommentaren wenn er mE wenn
wüs zum Thema findet da zwei Gesprächen
stammt ist zum Thema Media a viertigalt
und das Gespräch mit dem Autor rolfelli